welcome to this video this is cell to
know sad toes prove something okay so
probably has some flank opening a okay
maybe sick over the stone wall here
looks like it the stone wall without
white having played d4 it's a bit of a
shaky opening oh wow really but that's
very ambitious okay it's probably both
is good I mean he's much much behind in
development and has some weaknesses
there he five mostly so let's see how to
play that Nigeria mediately then
possibly d5 what d 5 immediately is also
good let's go d 5 it opens up quickly
yeah so let's see also night b5 is
interesting but that's good someone I
g51 I beehive it's both interesting yeah
let's start to go with them hard to say
so here we go hmm i thought 'if for
mites might have been interesting not
sure
so a 45 is the first thing that comes to
mind I think it's probably good right
yeah it pushes the night back to c8 that
cannot be bad really all the way back to
CN and b7 is under quite some pressure
yep so back to see a ton and now look
you one night bhai of this kind of thing
it's probably good Bishop h3 is also a
good move that's actually really good I
think g6 Bishop divorce is completely
unplayable and what what is this move
then if you cannot go G 695 now so 90
hive queen is six year
can be Queen takes b7 em check so some
Knight f6 is winning the house or Bishop
f6 oh yeah spoiled spoiled for choice
let's let's take this um this nothing
that he can do really also this one
check black resigns ja you can win
quickly also with c4 g3 stuff jano I'm
number of on questionable moves and
deform yeah this is really a mistake
it's not really questionable after e3 he
has no decent way to keep the center I
mean like c5 this is just terrible
position huge hole then I mean you can
count like 11 development two castles
rookie one yeah and he has moved bones
bones bones all the time and it's just a
week Rick everywhere that's not OK
Assateague and now I went here to
prevent e5 so just to make sure that bd7
and from here it is interesting you have
a couple of interesting options you can
also just just play against e6 now with
like Quincy to rock do you want like
this and just centralized they wanted to
be more more direct 95-96 this so now
the diagonal is open I think he should
maybe try a form i think f3 is still
good for white but this is a bit more
complicated at least here here white is
just enormously better ya know a 4 195
it's both got em now it's just a combat
zone plus one point something already so
Lex basically falling apart yeah here
well gee six losses losses really really
directly but yeah but whatever the else
have a five is attacked this position is
completely without any any sort of an
ordination check the idea one the house
yeah the the Stonewall versus some
English reti opening setups is a bit
questionable and still I mean if he goes
like night BTW 70 or something it's it's
it's you can play it it's not great but
you can play it d 4 is really not on ok
well thanks for watching